[Música]
su amplia sonrisa y sus pendientes de la
marca son reconocibles al instante
incluso después de 100 años la vaca que
ríe
producida por primera vez en la región
del yoga en el este de francia se vende
ahora en los cinco continentes el
logotipo nació a partir del dibujo de
una vaca alegre y que ilustraba los
trenes militares franceses que
abastecían de carne a las tropas en el
frente y ha evolucionado a lo largo del
siglo la base de la vaca estaba presente
desde 1921 pero con un estilo diferente
al principio la marca estaba
representada por una vaca con cuatro
patas detrás de un cartel porque el
fundador león bell quería algo que se
pudiera identificar como una vaca
lechera
la fórmula del éxito es sencilla un
queso blando y cremoso con un sabor
inconfundible pero el ingrediente más
importante probablemente sea una buena
dosis de misterio como es el caso de la
cocacola
ambos tienen lo que llamamos una fórmula
secreta durante más de un siglo esta
fórmula ha estado guardada bajo llave y
nadie la conoce
una receta casi intacta que sigue
gustando a pequeños y grandes